[Music]
foreign
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with journalist and
broadcaster Jenny cleeman and the daily
telegraphs associate editor for politics
Christopher hope they'll be with us from
now right up until just before midnight
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
trusts hit by minus strike is the pun on
the front of the Metro after the PM's
latest popularity poll rating amongst
party members which the paper says is a
record minus 70 percent
the eye says she could have more Peril
to come if as fared by many she drops
her pledge to keep the state pensions
triple lock
that's also the top story in the Daily
Mail
the telegraph also reports that it's one
option now being considered
but as the pension campaigning Daily
Express puts it don't dare go back on
pension triple lock
the guardian leads with what it calls
toxic budget cuts that are raising the
party pressure on the PN
the financial times reports that
Chancellor Jeremy Hunt is preparing to
raid the profits of Banks and energy
companies as he tries to balance the
nation's books after the tax u-turns
according to the times he may also
postpone the planned cap on social care
costs
while City am leads with the concerns of
the mayor of London that the recent
markets chaos is hitting investment in
the city
with strikes now being threatened across
the UK over the rising cost of living
the star says the country is heading
back to the industrial chaos of the
1970s
and with the NHS under particular stress
the mirror leads with the story of a war
hero who spent 26 hours on a hospital
trolley in a d before getting a bed
the sun reports that rail strikes will
hit bonfire night weekend with an
appropriate play on words for its
headline
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
journalist and broadcaster Jenny cleeman
and the daily telegraphs associate
editor for politics Christopher hope
welcome to both of you let's start with
the financial times and there from page
and as it alluded to when we ran through
the headlines there this is uh Jeremy
Hunt's suspected raiding of our energy
companies their profits and Banks to
make up the shortfall Christopher take
us into this story
well frankly what's the point of voting
Toria anymore many people might be
wondering here with this report in the
Ft generally have preparing there to
raise the properties of Banks and energy
companies to fill this 40 billion pound
fiscal hole in many ways the
government's trying to out labor labor I
mean what we saw
um Only Yesterday by the way it feels
like a last week or the week before that
only yesterday the the chance the junked
and hollowed out all of these um policy
ideas that quasi-gotanga brought out in
fact formed the basics The Hub that the
center point of um let's just campaign
to be Tori leader back in August
um and then we see him remove even the
cut in income tax that Rishi suno was
planning from 20p to 19p in April 2024
and now we're here today news of
windfall raids on Banks and energy
companies exactly what Liz trusted
against
um I don't know quite what the strategy
is it could be that the Tory government
is trying to be so like labor but labor
has nowhere to go that might be a policy
maybe I don't know because I think a lot
of stories might be wondering about this
yes sir Jenny and the the chancellor we
told us on the meeting of cabinet
ministers that they must exert tight
control on spending as he tries to prove
to the markets that he can bring the
deficit under control and that's what
it's all about isn't it really calming
the markets
yeah there was a kind of Airy calm in
Westminster today and the markets uh
were calmer but that's because everybody
is now waiting and speculating about uh
what the chancellor is going to say on
Halloween the the 31st of October
um and uh it was Jeremy Hunt's first uh
meeting with the cabinet as Chancellor
and Liz truss's only third meeting of
her entire cabinet uh lots of other
things mooted nothing off the table we
know that the Armed Forces Minister
James hepey and the defense minister Ben
Wallace have said they'll quit uh if the
government goes back on its pledge uh to
give three percent of GDP to defense but
we know the chancellor has said there's
going to be some eye-watering Cuts there
is this 40 billion pound uh black hole
in the finances that needs to be plugged
I mean clearly there needed to be a
massive change of Direction that's
what's happened that's why we have this
prime minister
still in post even though she has these
terrible approval ratings no one is yet
wanting to say that they will step up
and take her place they're trying
something completely different to see if
it can save her it probably won't be
enough but it may be enough uh to keep
this government afloat until Halloween
and the I Christopher concentrates on
pensions the u-turn on pensions uh
potentially dropping her promise to uh
increase pensions in line with inflation
that the triple lock
again it's almost exhausting the sea
soaring this government's doing between
left and right this is a further Lurch
really I would like you to the left here
because these are pensioners who the
Tories have promised to support for the
past decade really ever since David
Cameron came into office in 2010 this
pensions triple lock has been around or
in force and it and now to see this
disappear because
um Liz truss was asked about this why go
after
um benefits rather than pensions when
trying to cut uh uh spending this is
before the budget on the 23rd December
September when it was sent all the wrong
way and she see they said then the
government said then that pensions are
not often able to work to earn any more
money that's why pensioners need to have
their guaranteed uh rise in in uh in
their pensions more than other people
who may be able to work that was their
argument let's not have that argument
now that was the argument and to see
this now on the front page of the eye as
Jeremy Hunt saying nothing's off the
table and that they could actually
remove this triple lock it's a it's a
further kicking their teeth for people
who think that's what the Tory party for
Tory reasons
front of the Daily Express they say
don't dare go back on pension triple
lock do you think the Prime Minister
will consider not not you turning
Jenny yes you've asked him
um well I mean she she has to she has to
consider everything because she's in a
perilous State I mean this is for me
this makes me smile The Daily Express
they know their readership uh and the
Daily Express is normally relentlessly
positive when it comes to anything that
the the right wing of the conservative
party say but this sort of it's not even
A Veiled Threat it's a threat don't dare
go back on on the pension triple lock
um it's symbolically massive the triple
lock it's it's not just about keeping
people on fixed incomes uh in a safe
position it represents uh the Tories
saying to the constituency of people who
vote for them uh by and large but
they're on their side and a u-turn on on
these people is is potentially
incredibly dangerous but you know it
it's electorally very risky but it is it
is necessary and it's very difficult it
will be very difficult for the
government to make any argument about it
and not putting and not putting uh
public sector pay up whilst maintaining
maintaining this this promise that was
made in a completely different era let's
just bring Christopher in there what did
you want to say Christopher
well Jenny says it's necessary and is
not necessary I mean as all the politics
is Choice choices are made here and
there some might say that pensioners
deserve to have their triple lock that's
why the party won power in 2019 this is
all at the heart of this is a choice now
Liz truss made someone well I mean
Tories might argue that what was
announced on the 23rd of
um of uh September was was almost a more
of a wise budget it was all um all all
the right notes but not necessarily in
the right order in the sense that there
were good ideas there they just
presented them the wrong way in a rush
and spooked the markets
it's a different financial situation now
and now we have to we have to deal with
the aftermath of this you know the
economy is in a completely uh different
place and uh we cannot borrow to fill
this this black hole something has to
give no surprise in the Metro that the
prime minister is uh charting very low
in the popularity Stakes so she's more
unpopular than her predecessor Boris
Johnson who scored 53 the day he
resigned minus 53 and she's scoring
minus 70. Christopher
well quite I mean you know I think the
toys might hope that this has been a
long episode episode of Dallas like
Bobby Ewing they might wake up in the
shower and it's been a dream because
it's been a complete nightmare really I
think ever since the Tories stupidly I
think got rid of Boris Johnson I mean
they could have dealt with the issue
there and try to work his work his
problems out instead he lost the
confidence of his party than the country
and now he's somewhere else in the world
uh take it easy watching the chaos I
mean um for me at the heart of this is
it was anti-democratic to change a prime
minister Midway through apartment
without an election and the Tory party
is now reaping what they've sowed with
these appalling
um Marks here for this trust he's a six
out of ten uh speaker without any
policies it's a disaster
Christopher and Jenny thank you very
much for the moment we're going to take
a break coming up
the story of a war heroes 26 hour wait
on an AME trolley uh more on that when
we come back
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview still with me Jonathan
broadcaster Jenny cleeman and the daily
telegraphs associate editor for politics
Christopher hope let us have a look at
this um truly shocking story on the
front of the mirror this is the the tale
of Stanley Solomons who was left waiting
for 26 hours in a e just utterly
unbelievable Journey
I mean it is a shocking story but we
know that it's not extraordinary we've
heard many stories like this over the
summer uh and there have been reports
today that 300 000 patients have
experienced harm uh because of Handover
uh delays between ambulances and and a e
um these handovers they should take 15
minutes they're something like on
average three hours long it's really
really shocking it's the sort of thing
that you would expect to find in a
country which is a lot less wealthy in a
developing part of the world and this is
one of the many uh kind of symptoms of
our country being in such a poor State
at the moment I think a lot of people
have been feeling certainly over the
past few weeks that we're in a kind of
terminal decline here that things have
been and let to fester and get to such a
bad State
um that you have you know Veterans war
heroes
um leaving you know being left to to uh
to die when when you know we should be
doing whatever we can to to look after
these members of society so 95 years 95
years of age um but but this is the the
very thing that this new war room plan
this NHS plan to tackle the the winter
crisis is is going to try to prevent
Christopher
that's right and it's worth noting here
it's the second time that Stanley
Solomon's is a hero from Bletchley Park
the code Breakers has been left on a
trolley at a hospital for a long period
in 2019 the same paper the mirror
revealed that he'd been forced to wait
12 hours to be seen by a doctor at
Leicester Royal infirmary this 26 hour
delay happened in Nottingham this is
clearly unacceptable because the NHS is
all about throughput getting people from
the ambulance into a bed out of the bed
and home as quickly as possible that is
what the LH NHS is it's logistically
difficult and that's what's so
challenging challenging I think and we I
think the first half the program has
been discussing
um that the machinations of the
personality politics at the top of the
of the government but this is the meet
and drink of why it really matters and
why I think
um labor has a chance here to say to the
country in the election into your time
Britain isn't working I'm going to to
fix it and I think that that's an
opportunity here for labor they'll look
at these stories here they're appalling
it's outrageous they shouldn't happen
and voters might think well can labor do
better